vacances se sont interrompues
brutalement en congé sur l'archipel de
zanzibar
lorsque la russie a envahi leur pays ces
ukrainiens cherche à rentrer chez eux
rapidement mais les vols sont suspendus
notre fils et à kiev avec mes beaux
parents je ne sais pas comment nous
ferons partir le rejoindre
retrouver leurs proches se battre contre
l'envahisseur russe chacun ses raisons
pour rentrer au plus vite
nous ne voulons pas être dans un autre
pays
nous voulons entrer en ukraine pour
protéger notre patrie nous voulons nous
battre
qui sont coincés ici n'ont plus d'argent
pour payer des nuits d'hôtel
supplémentaires ou même pour s'acheter à
manger
la guerre ne les dissuade pas de partir
ils veulent être en famille le
gouvernement de zanzibar cherche à aider
ces touristes
nous sommes en contact avec
l'ambassadeur les tour opérateurs et les
hôtels
nous voulons leur proposer des vols pour
des pays voisins de l'ukraine et nous
avons demandé aux hôtels de les loger
dans ces moments difficiles
ces touristes espère qu'une fois en
ukraine ils trouveront bien leur
logement encore debout malgré les
bombardements